foreign
people we are live on the interwebs I'm
Dave Rubin it's September 9th
2022. this is the Reuben report and it's
time for another Friday Roundtable
Extravaganza joining me today is the
host of The Young Heretics show on
locals Spencer Clayton the host of
unapologetic live on prageru Amala
ekpenobi and the host of Viva Barnes law
also on locals Robert Barnes Spencer
Amela Robert welcome back to the Reuben
report good to be here
it is good to see you good people this
is our first panel show since I've
returned to the grid and obviously a lot
of nonsense happened in August and as as
I've been saying all week uh sometimes
it's hard to figure out what the
nonsense is because on social media uh
you can't quite tell what is real and
what isn't so that's kind of the theme
of the show today we're going to talk a
little bit about sort of top-down White
House censorship then we're going to
talk about the Democrats who are now
accusing all of us the four good people
you're seeing in these boxes right now
of being fascists and then the continued
orwellian and delusional rhetoric from
the Democrats and is Biden going to
actually finish this thing up we shall
see before we get to any of that let me
talk to you guys about real estate
agents I trust you guys know that buying
or selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent our homes
are often our biggest investment which
is a ton of responsibility and you need
an agent who takes that seriously that's
why I recommend real estate agents I
trust they work with only the best
agents in every Market they do their
homework talking to every agent before
inviting them to join their Network and
here's a big one they only work with
full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction and then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records they're the best sellers in
their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate
agentsitrust.com today give them some
basic info they'll reach out to you and
then you move to Florida and live
happily ever after and now back to me
okay so uh let's start with a little bit
of the collusion between big Tech and
big government because we've all known
that this has been going on for a while
we've played this a clip of Jen's sake
former White House Press Secretary Jen
saki many times where she flat out said
that the administration was flagging her
words flagging posts for Facebook
related to disinformation about covet
that's pretty much as close as you can
get to a First Amendment violation at
least as I see it uh well now uh here is
our new White House Press Secretary
Karin Jean-Pierre uh asked about uh
White House emails with social media
companies and it does seem that they've
been kind of colluded when it comes to
your speech so a federal judge talk
about the social media
three and Louisiana a federal judge
ordered that you have 20 days to turn
over emails of communicating with social
media companies over misinformation and
disinformation
um what are those emails going to show
what kind of community so I can't
comment you've asked me this question
last week I can't comment on any
specifically ongoing uh litigation and
so again I'd refer you we would refer
you to Department of Justice as we said
over and over again since the beginning
of the administration in our battle
against covid-19 it has been critical
for the American people to have access
to factual accurate science-based
information on information
so it's pretty spectacular what she's
doing there on one hand she's saying she
can't comment on anything and then the
last sentence there she's basically
saying but you know we clearly do this
have a little bit more from the New York
Post the Biden Administration worked in
tandem with social media giants like
Facebook and Twitter to censor
statements they deemed misinformation
about topics including the covid-19
pandemic two Republican state attorney
general said on Thursday as they push
for the release of emails between top
executive branch officials and big Tech
Titans in a petition filed Wednesday in
a Louisiana Federal Court State Attorney
General Jeff Landry and his Missouri
counterpart Eric Schmidt charged that
dozens of federal office officials
across at least 11 federal agencies
engaged in a massive sprawling Federal
censorship Enterprise with the intent
and effect of pressuring social media
platforms to censor and suppress private
speech that Federal officials disfavor
the the Attorney General said they have
ident identified at least 45 people
within HHS and the Department of
Homeland Security who have communicated
with social media companies about
misinformation all right Robert to you
first you are my official lawyer here at
the Reuben report or unofficial or
something like that but if a government
let's say the United States government
the federal government
talks to these
social media companies and they get as
close to saying hey we're going to shut
you down and we're going to break you up
or you better do this or something like
that what is the point where this
becomes an actual violation of the First
Amendment which as everyone knows who's
watching this it's about government
censorship but they're they're really
pushing that line right
uh no doubt I mean if you go back to the
Banta books U.S Supreme Court case that
that Case established where any
government agency is using any coercive
tool to uh to basically censor speech at
any level is a First Amendment violation
now the problem is the federal courts
have been reluctant to extend that
Doctrine to the big Tech context uh one
of the main cases that's going to be
deciding this issue is the ninth circuit
case involving Robert Kennedy his suit
against Facebook on the grounds they
were acting as a government agent and
his reason for believing that was based
on just a little bit of the information
that these two attorney generals have
Unearthed by filing a lawsuit
challenging what's taking place what
this discovery exposed and there's more
Discovery to come the judges ordered
fauci to produce all of his
Communications and all of his staffs and
teams Communications uh and within uh
three weeks by the end of September and
so that will probably be provide even
more revelatory information it was
clearly so rattling the big Tech that
Zuckerberg went on Joe Rogan and said oh
by the way the FBI is the one who really
told me to suppress the hunter Biden
laptop story he knew this was going to
be coming out in some capacity anyway
but this is what we've long suspected
it's just once the bite Administration
took over it became systematic and
institutionalized and it's across all
agencies not just the Department of
Homeland Security or or HHS they found
evidence of it with the FBI they found
evidence of it with other government
agencies basically government agencies
that have extraordinary power over big
Tech with those high-ranking officials
not low-level people doing what the
disinformation governance board was
going to officially informally
coordinate had already been informally
occurring for for the entire Biden
Administration and this should be a
First Amendment violation the question
is whether federal courts will step up
to it and recognize it as such under
existing precedent so Robert just on the
legal side before I jump to the other
guys is the issue here I mean I watched
and I'm sure everyone that's watching
this saw at least some of the clips of
Zuckerberg on Facebook and he never flat
out said hey they contacted us and they
said we're going to break you up or
we're going to use antitrust legislation
or we're going to send Regulators in or
you know you know open your books check
their algorithm that basically they got
a call like oh there's some stuff going
on we just kind of want you to know so
that's what makes this tough to to
really go after somebody right because
they get as close to that line as
possible without moving over it exactly
they've been playing this game where
they they'll say hey I really hope you
could help us out here and then maybe
next week they say way as the White
House by the way did this week maybe we
need some big Tech reform and we need to
take away your immunity or and escalate
Anti-Trust actions so the message is
clear big Tech knows what's happening
and the key is for courts to acknowledge
and admit that this is the implicit
reality but they're playing a game by
not making it explicit in Express
I'm like you guys at Prager you know a
little something about being suppressed
and there have been lawsuits against
Google and YouTube and all of that stuff
I mean are we basically at the point
where for any of us that do something
like this for a living we just kind of
have to just put our hands up and be
like hey we're on these platforms and
just until we're not and and that's it
or or they'll just censor us to the
point that we think we're doing
something that people are seeing but
they're not really seeing it right I
mean it's a tough line to walk there I
hope these lawsuits are successful in
their Endeavors but like you said we're
no strangers to this sort of censorship
we've been dealing with it for a very
long time I think the video that we got
taken down that really sparked us
engaging in a lawsuit with Google was a
video about the Ten Commandments being
taken down and censored by prageru so
it's it's unbelievable it's something
that I unfortunately am not super
optimistic about I feel like they have a
pretty synergistic relationship between
big Tech and the government and they
don't want to see that relationship
disbanded yeah this is like you know
will no one rid me of this meddlesome
priest you know when Henry II wanted to
get rid of Thomas Beckett it said that
he didn't give the order to have him off
he just you know mentioned in the
presence of his Knights that this is a
guy that he would really like to see
gone and lo and behold of course then
you know you've got a basically a
paramilitary force flocking to
Canterbury to get this guy out of the
way it's exactly what's going on between
the big tech companies and the
government and I think it really gives
the lie to this ongoing kind of shrug
that we get from some quarters that oh
these are private companies they can do
whatever they like I mean Dave you sort
of mentioned this and I think we need to
recognize that these entities are not
these little like Plucky garage startups
as as Robert were saying you know they
they don't just kind of come along and
sell you their product and their
products really great and oh well if
they want to kick you off they can kick
you off I mean this is these have been
buttressed by government funds
government uh you know blowback for
years and years you know Google has been
entangled with the FBI and the CIA and
it shouldn't come as a surprise now that
we're seeing that these deals are going
on you know more and more in public
because these companies have really
become a kind of Paris State entity and
we need to regard them as such yeah to
that point Robert do you do you think
that we're almost in too deep at this
point like when you see now that there
are people saying there are analysts who
are saying that as much as 80 percent of
Twitter or might be Bots not five
percent that Elon was willing to go with
but it could be eighty percent or that
we know that the feeds are crazy
manipulated and the YouTube uh
recommended videos can send you off down
wherever they want to send you as
opposed to what you might actually want
that were so deep in the nonsense that
even if some lawsuit gets something
exposed or something is broken up or
whatever that it's almost it's almost
we're just we're just long gone we're
past the point where there could be any
uh return to sanity let's say
I mean I think if the courts were smart
they could Salvage the situation by
reinstating The Old Company Town
Doctrine and that was when the company
owns the Public Square then the company
has an obligation to abide by the First
Amendment called the pruneyar doctrine
in California if they would apply this
to Big corporations that have Monopoly
power in the big Tech space and social
media to the digital Public Square they
could solve this problem uh but
unfortunately it's not clear whether the
courts are willing to step into the
breach and what you identify is what's
become the functional reality which may
require legislative reform ultimately or
in lieu thereof people simply
giving punishment to these big Tech
agencies and big Tech institutions by
going out to Independent alt Tech uh you
see people like Rumble doing well you
see others doing well ultimately the
market competition is probably going to
be the key means to do so but it's tough
to be in Market competition when you
have big Tech big government
monopolistic collusion yeah I want to
give you a last word on this but even
just to prove the point I mean we know
in the last week or so since I've been
back my channel on YouTube is getting
just crushed people are not seeing you
know subscribe to people are not seeing
it we know that the search is all out of
whack I've contacted YouTube we haven't
heard back yet but the point is the
amount the people that are watching this
right now
it we we have no idea how many people it
actually went out to that want to get it
so that's why we're in this very weird
you think oh I clicked something a
subscriber a notification I will see it
but then you just don't know and then
you just forget that certain people
exist I'm the last word on this one yeah
I mean we're constantly being throttled
if you look back at Google's history you
know their catchphrase used to be don't
be evil and they've since they've since
gotten rid of that because they think
they're engaged in some pretty nefarious
nefarious things here and I I would
recommend to the audience there's this
brilliant documentary called the creepy
line which talks about Google and in
sort of the big Tech history behind some
of these search engines and softwares
and the amount of of power they have
over what you see what you hear what you
think and feel is unbelievable they can
really shape the way our society moves
as far as elections go without you even
being able to detect their bias and to
think that the government is not
utilizing that in some way is pretty
naive to me yeah you gave me a perfect
segue for the next part because you know
they keep accusing us all of being
fascists and yet they're the one who the
ones who are using corporations and
state power to silence us but as you
guys know irony is dead uh let me talk
about the blaze real quick and then
we'll move on to that as you guys know I
was gone in August uh Larry Elder my
good buddy Larry Elder gave me a rundown
of all that happened when I was away and
it was a ton I can tell you I was not
surprised to hear that Zuckerberg helped
the FBI that goes with what we're
talking about right now uh I wasn't
surprised to hear that Gavin Newsom is
destroying California well if you want
to think of MSNBC like California and
Blaze TV like Florida then you should be
subscribing to Blaze TV because you'd
have to be believe
oh wow I'm reading this thing all
backwards
the point is MSNBC and Cali are no good
The Blaze is where you're going to get
real news it's why I'm a partner of the
Blaze and right now if you use code
Reuben 20 this week only you can get a
20 discount off an annual subscription
we're heading into the midterms and
you're going to want to get news from a
network that isn't run by democrats or
the spouses of Democrats use promo code
Reuben for twenty dollars off your first
year subscription to Blaze TV it's time
to normalize Free Speech okay so they
keep calling us fascists even though
they're the ones using fascist tactics
uh and uh Hillary Clinton she's back and
yeah she's using the words here we go
you know look fascism is a very big word
I know that but so is socialism and the
Republicans call every Democrat who
wants people to have health care a
socialist so I think we do need to be
careful with our language but I think
the problem is if you go through the
Hallmarks of authoritarian regimes you
see too many
characteristics unfortunately
on our Republican side and my most
fervent hope is that Republicans
themselves will begin to reject all of
that verbally vocally in their voting
and you know kind of reconstitute the
Republican party to where it used to be
and not the you know party of trump
which I think is very dangerous
ah so there you go on network corporate
news you have six Democrats and one
woman who's pretending to be a
republican Allison Farrah but she's a
Democrat too corporation uh all giving
you one point of view calling the rest
of us fascists Spencer I don't think
you're surprised by this are you well
first of all this is highly
irresponsible rhetoric on the part of
the former first lady Hillary Clinton
we're only semi-fascists we Mega
Republicans and the president has said
it's like low calorie fascism you know
it's just a little bit look I'm I'm
really glad that somebody like Hillary
Clinton has finally you know stood up
called to spade a spade and called out
the political party that is censoring
speech that is using the doj and the FBI
to beat down the door of their political
opponents and investigate a former
president in a completely unprecedented
fashion the party that racially
demonizes vast swaths of the country and
Compares other swaths to a disease oh
wait I'm sorry I got that wrong that's
the Democrats do all of those things so
I mean look this is an old old leftist
tactic Theodore dorno the um you know
the German Marxist famously came up with
this thing in the 50s called the f scale
the fascist scale and it was a
measurement of how fascist are you and
it was things like you know do you enjoy
physical culture and weightlifting are
you aggressive are you you know sexually
overconfident and you know these sorts
of things go way way back it is an
obvious socialist tactic to use the word
that Clinton thinks I shouldn't say it's
it's a it's a Marxist tactic for
delegitimizing your political opposition
for writing as much of the country out
of existence out of political existence
and political legitimacy as you want
that's the game Biden's playing that's
the game Clinton's playing and they're
doing it because it's the only thing
they have to offer for the midterms all
they can do everything that they touch
turns to disaster all they can do is say
look look it's the evil mag of
Republican fascists and you know God
willing I I don't actually think this is
a good tactic I don't think calling half
the country uh evil is is a way to win
votes and by the way to your point that
every other day there's an article on
slate or one of these idiotic sites
saying that if you're fit that means
you're a fascist that now working out
and looking good and caring about your
repair words and eating right is the
Nazi Hallmark but the endless sort of
Hysteria that Hillary just showed right
there it's just coming from almost every
Democrat at this point I would love to
find a Democrat who wasn't doing it and
I would gladly have them on the show and
treat them the same way I treat you guys
and all my other guests uh GQ ran a
crazy fluff piece cover piece with AOC
this week and there's some real gems in
there just to talk about how they're
ramping up the insanity I got some
quotes here from you from AOC this is
the GQ piece on AOC over the course of
our conversations the congresswoman
typically answered in a confident
fast-paced pattern each sentence closely
chasing the tale of the last but now her
speech slowed to a crawl and for the
first time in the hours we had spent
speaking she broke eye contact burying
her gaze in the arm of her chair tears
pooled in the corners of her eyes Jesus
Christ I'm gonna barf that was me uh I
hold two contradictory things in mind at
the same time one is just the Relentless
belief that anything is possible she
said but at the same time my experience
here has given me a front row seat to
how deeply and unconsciously as well as
consciously so many people in this
country hate women and they hate women
of color people ask me questions about
the future and realistically I can't
even tell you if I'm going to be alive
in September and that weighs very
heavily on me and it's not just the
right wing misogyny transcends political
ideology left right or Center this grip
of patriarchy affects us all not just
women men as I mentioned before but also
ideologically there's an extraordinary
lack of self-awareness in so many places
and so those are two very conflicting
things I admit to sometimes believing
that I live in a country that would
never let that happen I'm a little
confused here because I've done many
public events with you and as far as I
know I don't care about such things but
you are a woman and a woman of color I
have seen all sorts of people give you
standing ovations and sign autographs
and take selfies these are supposed to
be scary racist white supremacists is
AOC a little confused or maybe drunk
what's going on here you know there's a
lot to unpack there she said she didn't
know if she was going to make it until
September if that's the timeline that
we've got right now I need to get going
on that bucket list
um but I it seems like she's having a
really really hard time and I don't know
whether or not this is theatrical
because we know she's gone to the Border
fence and cried she thought she was
going to die on January 6th but I would
like to take a comment like that I don't
think I will make it until September or
I don't know if I'll make it to
September very seriously but what does
she think is going to happen is it
climate that's going to kill her is it
the Maga Republicans who are coming
after her or is it her own mental health
and if it is that we should be taking it
seriously it's just really hard with all
the theatrics that she is constantly
engaged in to take a comment like that
seriously Robert really stunning and
brave of you omelette to just sit there
while Dave assumed your gender
I should cancel him you are yeah I
didn't say it you did you know Robert
Robert is it I mean look I know irony is
dead and all of that stuff but you know
when she says you know she's the victim
in all this I mean what what lays
beneath everything she said there is
that she is a victim for whatever reason
she's a victim at the same time she's
calling everyone else these horrible
things does she not realize that could
cause a situation where perhaps they
won't make it to September because of
her inflammatory language is that
totally lost on her
well I think both AOC and Hillary's
statements reflect confession through
projection which is one of my favorite
sayings because it's people who if you
get randomly accused of something that
makes no sense by somebody just assume
that they're confessing themselves and
they're describing their own behavior
and that's what like AOC saying man
there's a lot of lack of self-awareness
in the world that precisely summarizes
AOC utter lack of self-awareness
completely there's politics of
narcissism this sort of Instagram driven
politics of people that completely lack
self-awareness it's their defining
aspect and then the same with Hillary
this is someone who tried to create
fascistic aspects in our own government
with her ties to various operations and
inside and outside government the
Clinton Foundation being the most
notoriously Corruption of our government
in recent modern history uh until the
Biden family took over the White House
and and yet here she's talking about
someone who weaponized the FBI who's
bragging selling merchandise over the
fact that she destroyed a bunch of
emails that were actually work
classified while the president gets
raided for things that he had a legal
right to declassify so it shows the
degree of absurdity that is occurring uh
but it's both their cases of confession
through projection
Spencer when uh when they treat her like
the queen uh and then they treat sort of
Republican women horribly Myra Flores
who's the new congresswoman from Texas
is a great example this woman wins a
seat in a Border Town in Texas you know
a month and a half ago or so first time
a Republicans had the seat in over a
hundred years the New York Times writes
an article and I quote the rise of the
far right Latina but again it's the
double standard thing that we we just
need to move past it right I mean do we
need to keep calling it out or should we
just let it go and figure out a better
way to fight back
I just think it's important with the
with the comment that Hillary made to to
point out what authoritarianism looks
like and it looks like big government
expansion of regulations Mass censorship
and stabbing off political dissidents
and that's exactly what they're engaged
in
yeah
Spencer
I certainly think we can get over the
you know Democrats or the real racists
pulling out our hair running around on
fire like this is who they are they've
told us who there are a million times
we've seen it over and over and over
again we know they're going to behave
this way and we do need to develop some
strategies not just for complaining
about it but actually pushing back
against it electing people that will
kick these guys out of office and so on
and and so forth it all does however
raise the really important question
which is when can we expect the AOC
guest spot on Meghan markle's new
podcast this is I think the country
demands to know we need this appearance
and they do deserve each other I mean
Britain is mourning the death of its
Monarch as we speak and you know she
leaves behind her a royal family that is
in some ways in shambles precisely
because of this this trend that's going
on on both sides of the Atlantic people
governing uh not only by emotion and
victimization but also narcissism and
and self-glamorization that's you know
again all AOC has to offer she's very
good at it she looks great in that GQ
shoot you have to hand it to her
um but I think the the thing that we've
got to get better at is just
acknowledging that these these people
are you know pandering fascistic bigots
and we gotta you know move past that and
and uh and fight our own battles Spencer
you just gave me the greatest segue of
all time because speaking of
narcissistic self-glamorizing
Etc people uh Barack Obama was back at
the White House this week uh with
Michelle and they had their White House
portraits unveiled and hilariously uh
Barack thinks things are going pretty
well right now because of Old Joe all
did together
to expand Health Care to fight climate
change
to advance social justice
and to promote economic fairness
thanks to your decency and thanks to
your strength
maybe most of all thanks to your faith
in our democracy and the American people
the country is better off than when you
took office and we should all be deeply
grateful for that so thank you so much
Robert can you lay out a couple reasons
that maybe the country isn't better off
right now than it was under Donald Trump
well I mean that's uh ordinary Americans
complete expectations is that the
economy has tanked that our Societies in
disarray we have a complete debacle in
Afghanistan we have a ongoing war that
may lead to World War III in both
Ukraine and Taiwan so most people don't
consider massive Scandal explosive risk
of war and a completely collapsing
economy is a sign of a president who's
done a good job
Avila is the key there to the Obama
thing what you know okay so he says
climate change and health care but the
key really was the third thing when he
says social justice that that really is
what has driven this entire
Administration they have hired a series
of completely incompetent people based
on skin color or gender or sexual
identity and everything else but that
really that's what what is driving this
whole thing and maybe it's really Obama
behind this because obviously Joe ain't
driving the car
you know he's had a few too many trips
to the White House Obama he's been
keeping it very close and with this
candidacy and with this with this
President and like I say David it's
never been a better time to be me in
America I could be working in the white
house right now with absolutely no
qualifications and what Robert said is
right you know you can call Joe Biden a
fantastic president and say that he's
doing amazing things for this country
but when people walk out their front
door and see the state of their
communities they're going to know that
that is not the case no matter how
charismatic Obama is
so okay I get all four of us people can
look at these four boxes and go okay
wait a minute you guys aren't Democrats
you don't like these people this this is
too easy so Spencer I'm going to give
you the hardest question of the day
which is let's try to give the devil his
due here has Biden done anything good is
anything being done right is is are we
just really missing something are we all
being hyper partisan is there anything
here that this man I mean that speech
can you get anything out of that great
Nazi speech I mean is there anything
let's try here
well what you really have to give him
credit for of course is that he did
lower the temperature you know of our
politics he brought us back to normalcy
exactly as he promised this was the
premise of his entire campaign is that
he was going to be not Trump and I think
we can all agree that he's not Trump
trump presided over a great economy he
managed a lot of excellent trade deals
he broker to you know step toward peace
in the Middle East none of that is
happening under under Biden so he has
delivered on his promise of being not
Trump I I also think that it makes
perfect sense that Obama you know thinks
uh thinks things are going great under
Biden because he's probably closer to
running the country under Biden than
Biden himself is I mean that's one thing
we could say Biden may have done well is
is uh be incompetent or be ineffectual
you know so much of his uh so many of
his efforts have fallen flat especially
in in Congress and the overreach that
we've seen come out of this Democrat
Party not just Biden but the uh
legislators they've elected has been a
gift to the country in the sense that
we've seen the kind of extremism that
lurks underneath the sort of friendly
Uncle Joe uh return to normalcy you
tried man you really I did my best I
appreciate that so so Biden you know
we're used to him misreading the
teleprompter or forgetting what he's
saying or going with the crazy story or
making up words or anything else but
here was a gaffe that happened a little
bit uh later after Obama and uh former
First Lady Michelle Obama spoke
um Biden didn't even have to speak and
still screwed something up
Joe honestly everybody stood with Joe
first off that that poor sign language
lady having to laugh at this but
literally everyone in the room stood up
for Jill for Dr Jill Biden I don't want
to get in any trouble with Dr Jill Biden
and Joe forgot to stand up
Robert is he going to make it is he
going to make it for the four years of
this thing or what I mean we're barely
two years in
I think they would like to remove them
but their problem is as almost every
poll shows with my buddy Richard Barris
of people's pundit basically everybody
out like you asked what is Biden's best
asset he's not the alternative he's not
Kamala Harris you know he's not beat
Buddha dead he's not Hillary Clinton he
he's not Gavin Newsom uh when these
people poll against Trump trump crushes
him and so they're they're stuck with
them they're stuck with a living walking
talking dementia candidate in the white
house and they can't find a way out of
it and they use him as a figurehead even
though he's an increasingly embarrassing
figurehead of the of the corrupt regime
that the white house now represents
under the Biden Administration and it's
incompetence as well but they don't have
a they don't have a backup that there's
no relief pitcher here to help there's
no backup quarterback to come in and
save them that's their problem is it
crazy Amala how thin their benches that
you know everyone knows Biden is
compromised and you know I I said it the
day he was inaugurated I do I still
believe it I don't think he's going to
make it all four years I don't see how
so it won't just collapse at some point
either them forcing him out or him
having like a true full-on breakdown you
know on camera and they won't be able to
hide it anymore but that there as Robert
says it's like Kamala polling at zero in
her own party when they plucked her for
VP nobody really likes gay Pete like the
whole crew it's like there's there's
just nothing there
right I think they gave themselves away
too quickly and just normal reasonable
rational people of all sorts and of all
sides of the aisle cannot get behind
anybody who's on their roster and I want
to say something nice I have a lot of
sympathy for for Jill Biden for for
standing so strong and having to cover
up every single embarrassing Gaff that
happens with her husband I mean he
clearly doesn't stand unless told to
stand so I'm sort of with you Dave I
don't know that he's gonna make it and
that's not something that I'm cheering
on or excited about I quite literally
feel bad for him that he's being used as
a puppet right now in his presidency but
that might be Karma you know for the
record I think you can make the complete
reverse argument about Jill though
because she knows if anyone knows what's
really wrong with him and whatever drugs
he's on or whatever they're doing to him
to prop him up there she knows so in
some ways I get what you're saying about
having sympathy for her because it's
embarrassing but in another way it's
like who's more evil in this situation
like is it the political hack that's
using him or Obama or his own wife
that's using him Spencer bring us home
on that positive note
well I mean I think you guys are all
just being way too unkind to Biden all
they have to do is write stand up on his
little cheat sheet and you know that's
right the president stands up you know
he's the president stands up and you are
the president yes you the President
Obama which is also you stand up right I
mean it's the staffer's fault they're
not no I um uh I am nothing will
surprise me at this point and so I am
agnostic I think about whether he's
going to make it whether they can really
force him through across the finish line
but I I think the point about the
thinness of the bench is really crucial
they have a serious problem on their
hands which is that all the energy all
the Youth of the party is concentrated
in this tiny Vanguard that believes
absolutely whackadoodle Bonkers Crazy
Town things about the most basic
questions of human life like male and
female right or race even you know
things that are not just anti-American
but anti-commonsense anti-human and and
to put that out in front of a political
party is simply a no-go it's simply you
know not going to fly they have to do
their best to warp the minds of children
into accepting it but that's not going
to pay off for another 20 years so what
do they do you know they have to find
somebody that looks like a normal dude
um yeah they're the closest like analog
the next best thing is Pete bootage Edge
and you know one shutters to think that
that's the closest thing they have to a
normal person I I don't know it's uh
it's rough it's rough going for them and
uh and I hope that they uh they suffer
for it politically on that note I just
like to say that the three of you or
three of my favorite fascists and I hope
you have I hope you have a great weekend
and uh all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
finish up without you but uh we'll we'll
do you three together another time I
really enjoyed this so thank you guys
have a good weekend wonderful thanks
David thanks David thank you all right
people our first week back on the grid
is about to come to a close uh actually
baby Justin made his first uh in studio
appearance right before we started the
live stream maybe well I don't want to
use him as a prop but I know the people
want to see him he we've been showing
some pictures in locals but maybe I'll
just plop them here and uh we'll see
what happens next week anyway let me get
to a couple comments uh from locals and
then I'll tell you about a few things
that are coming up soon Maddie says
where is the content warning for the
view clips
Connor
or supposed to put the warning
all right no guacamole for you with the
Chipotle today uh sorry about that
Maddie you you oh by the way something
hilarious is probably happening on The
View right now as you guys know the view
which is this crazy Harpy sitting at
this table you know screaming all day
long so I just saw this right before we
started so Anna Navarro you know her
she's called me racist on Twitter before
just a nut bag
um she used to be a republican she
worked for Marco Rubio then she decided
she wanted to be a TV star so she you
know she's a I don't know if she's a
Democrat she's just an idiot but uh she
they have Charlie Christ on the show
today now Charlie Christ is the guy
running against Ron DeSantis and
everyone knows he's going to get
obliterated and there is no real
functioning Democratic party here in
Florida so they just threw him up he's a
former Republican Governor he used to be
a Republican and people used to hate him
because he was anti-gay a lot of people
think he's gay it's a whole thing here
it doesn't matter with this clown
um but Anna Navarro somebody it's
Brendan Leslie this guy uh Brandon
Leslie uh who's a reporter down in South
Florida he found like a whole slew of
tweets from Anna Navarro calling Charlie
Chris the worst things in the world so
Charlie Christ is on The View today and
I do hope that Anna Navarro has the
balls
to read those Tweets in front of Charlie
Christ I think not but we'll find some
clips because I'm sure something
hilarious is going on right now we'll
play that on Monday a couple other
comments Amy Says saying that Gavin
Newsom destroyed California is basically
saying it's Tuesday yeah
we didn't even get into Gavin today but
he I mean all the things we talked about
about accusing everyone of what you are
doing and all of that confession through
projection I mean it is Gavin Newsom
101. Tony says YouTube might as well be
called wetube since it's basically Kami
yeah it's really unfortunate you know it
did not have to be this way and you know
YouTube it's a little hard for you as
the viewer you you see these videos or
you don't see these videos and you think
okay well I tap subscribe maybe there's
a bug or this happened that happened or
you don't think about it because you got
your own life and you know watching this
or watching anything else it's just a
small piece of your life as it should be
um but you know as someone that does
this for a living and and has businesses
built around this when they go out of
our their way to hide Us in search or
when you the subscriber doesn't see our
videos you know not only does it affect
the bottom line and that that's one
thing we're doing okay
um it's that you know it makes it harder
to spread the message so anyway that's
why we are live streaming on Rumble
every day and I do hope that you're
subscribed and watching over there and
joining us at the locals community Unity
reubenreport.locals.com part three of my
interview with Jared Kushner is up on
Rumble and YouTube right now the full
thing's up absolutely ad free on
locals.com I wish you a happy Friday and
a wonderful weekend and we'll be back on
Monday